So far we've dealt with simple
chains and rings of carbons.
But let's think about what
happens when things get a
little bit more complex.
Let me just draw a molecule here
and we can think about
how we'll name it.
So let me draw it like that.
So here we don't have
a simple chain.
It branches off at some point.
So what we do in this situation
is we find the
longest chain in this molecule,
and let's think
about what the longest
chain is.
If we start here we get one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight carbons.
If we start here we get one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine carbons.
So what we do is we look
at the longest chain.
The longest chain is this
one right here.
Let me do this in a
different color.
So this is one, two, three, one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight,
nine carbons.
And so this will be-- that will
be kind of the core of
our naming.
So it's nine carbons.
So that right here, longest
chain, has nine carbons.
You can kind of view this is the
backbone of our molecule
and also the backbone
of our naming.
Nine carbons, so we're dealing
with a nonane.
Remember, nine, non- for nine,
and then -ane, because we're
dealing with an alkane.
We have all single
bonds over here.
Now, what do we do with
this thing over here?
Well, what's kind of sticking
off of this chain?
Well, we essentially have one
carbon here that's attached to
the chain, right?
This carbon is bonded to
a carbon on the chain.
If we wanted to draw the entire
molecule, we could draw
carbon here and it would it be
bonded to three hydrogens, but
that is all implicit.
But what is this thing
right here?
Well, it's one carbon.
You might be tempted to say
it's methane, but it's not
methane because it's attached
to other things.
But it would be right to
use the prefix meth-.
So this right here, you would
use the prefix meth-, so this
is one carbon, so you would want
to use the prefix meth-,
but because it isn't the main
chain, it is added to
something else, we don't write
methane, we write methyl.
So let me write this
right here: methyl.
So this means it branches
off longer chain.
So this molecule right here
would be called-- and
actually, there's one
more thing that we
have to think about.
This thing could have been--
we could just call it
methylnonane.
Let me just write that
down right now.
So we could just call this
right from the get-go, we
could call it methylnonane.
But there's one problem with
just calling it methylnonane.
This is methylnonane, but so
what's-- let me draw it.
So the thing I just drew here,
this is, one, two, three,
four, one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine.
So that's the nonane.
And the one I drew here's one,
two, three, the methyl is
right over here.
That's what I just drew.
That is-- let me do it
in the same color.
So this is what I just drew.
But maybe, what if it was
something like this?
What if it was one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine?
And let's say that the methyl
group was, instead of being
right here, let's say the methyl
group was right here.
So how would you name these
two things differently?
This name right now does not
differentiate between the
methyl group being on this
carbon versus the methyl group
being on this carbon over here
or this carbon over there.
And what you do in this case is
you number the carbons on
the longest chain, on the main
backbone, and you number them
so that the methyl group is
attached to the lowest
possible number.
So there's two possible ways
to number this chain.
You could start here
as one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
Then you would say that this
would be that the methyl group
is attached to the
seven carbon.
Or you could start numbering
from this end of the chain.
It would be one, two, three.
Or so it could also be attached
to the third.
Three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine.
So you want to number
it so you're closest
to the methyl group.
So you want to start here.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
So in this case, this would
not just be methylnonane.
This thing right here
would be three.
Let me make this very clear.
It would be 3-methylnonane.
Because the methyl group, that
one carbon, that one CH3, is
attached to the third carbon
on our nonane backbone, so
that right there is
3-methylnonane.
Since I drew this out, what
is this right here?
Well, once again, we have this
nonane backbone, one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, and you want to
number it so that this methyl
group is at the lowest number
carbon as possible.
So it's closer to this
end than that end.
So it's one, two, three, four,
I'll do that in magenta, and
you can keep numbering, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
So this one is going to be four,
and then you have your
methyl group.
It's just one carbon sitting
right there, so
4-methylnonane.
Now, let's go the other
way around.
Let's say we start with the name
and we want to figure out
its formula.
And hopefully, this gives you
a good understanding how
things will get more complex.
And over the next few videos,
they'll get more and more
complex, but you'll
see it's all at
least reasonably logical.
So let's say I were to give
you let me think of one.
Let's say 2-propylheptane.
So how do we take this apart?
So the first thing you
see, it is an alkane.
It's all going to
be single bonds.
Heptane, this is kind
of the core.
So the longest chain here, hept-
is the prefix for seven.
So this tells us-- let
me make this clear.
This tells us that we're dealing
with all single bonds.
That's what the -ane tells us.
If we had double bonds,
it would be -ene,
triple bonds, -ine.
We're going to see that in the
future, but let's stay
simple right now.
The hept- tells us we're dealing
with seven carbons.
And then what does this
2-propyl mean?
Well, propyl tells us-- what
was the prop- prefix?
If methyl is one, ethyl is two,
propyl is three, butyl is
four, so this is a three-carbon
group, and it's
going to be attached to the
second carbon on the heptanes.
Let me draw the heptane chain.
So we have seven carbons, so
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven.
And then on the second carbon--
just let me pick a
good color here.
On the second carbon, so if we
just number it one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
on the second carbon right
there, we have a propyl group.
We have a propyl group, but it
is a three-carbon group.
So let me draw the
propyl group.
So we have a one, two, three,
three-carbon group, and it's
attached at the second
carbon right there.
So this molecule,
2-propylheptane
looks just like this.
Let's do another one, maybe one
that seems a little bit
more difficult.
Let's say that we have
6-butyltetradecane.
And all of these might seem a
little daunting when you see
it at first, but if you really
just break it up, it actually
is pretty logical.
So once again, we have the -ane
there, so it's all going
to be single bonds.
What is tetradec-?
What is that prefix?
Well, dec- is 10 and then
we have tetra-, that's 4
plus 10, that's 14.
Tetradec- is 14.
So this is telling us
that we're dealing
with a 14-carbon chain.
Let's draw that.
So one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine,
ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen,
fourteen carbon chain.
And if we number them, one, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven,
twelve, thirteen,
fourteen, this tells us that
the sixth carbon will be
butyl, will be a butyl group.
So let's see, the sixth
carbon is right here.
And butyl, and you should
memorize this, methyl is one,
ethyl is two, propyl is three,
butyl is four, so we have a
four-carbon group.
So let me write this
in a pink maybe.
So this is a four-carbon
group.
When you call it an alkyl
group, it's attached to
something else.
So on the sixth carbon, we have
a four-carbon group, so
one-- let me draw it this way.
No, this is fine.
Let's say we have one, two,
three, four, so that is our
butyl right there, and it's
attached to the sixth carbon.
It's attached to the sixth
carbon right there.
So this is what our molecule
would look like.
Now, let me ask you
a question.
Would you ever see a
9-butyltetradecane?
So something where-- so let
me redraw it like this.
So a 9-butyltetradecane, so it
would have butyl over here.
One, two, three, four, one,
two, three, four.
Would you ever see a
9-butyltetradecane?
Will you ever see
that written?
You might say, oh, yeah,
Sal, you just drew it.
And the reason why you won't
ever see that written is
because there's a better
way to number it
if it's like this.
Instead of starting over here at
one at this end, you'd want
to start one that end.
So instead of saying
9-butyltetradecane, you should
number it the other way.
You should say this is one, two,
three, four, five, six.
So this is actually also
6-butyltetradecane.
Let me be sure I got that.
One, two, three, four,
five, six.
So instead of starting from the
left and making this the
ninth carbon, you always want
to start numbering from the
direction that has the lowest
number for the first group.